what's going on guys this is Rob and as
you guys know we have been building up
to Deadpool kills Deadpool and in truth
we've actually got to finish this quick
because the death of Deadpool is coming
up really really fast I think it's issue
number 45 with a current one I'm
Deadpool and we're on issue number 44 so
we've got a very limited amount of time
before we get into the story of Deadpool
dying so because we're celebrating the
fact that Ryan Reynolds is playing the
role of Deadpool and because Deadpool is
going to be right at our thank God for
that we're going to be calling Deadpool
from the earth-616 in this video Ryan
Reynolds and we're going to be calling
the Deadpool from Deadpool I guess kills
the Marvel Universe all that stuff dark
pool just so we can differentiate
between the two now for those of you
guys who are new to this whole thing I
would highly suggest you go back and
watch watch the videos about Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe Deadpool Killa
straight of the Deadpool Corps that way
you can be current if you're not
familiar with those elements of the
Deadpool stories so with that being said
let's jump into it so here's the deal
what happens is we pick up with zombie
Deadpool and if you guys recall we did
that big 15 minute video explaining
zombie Deadpool and we talked about
zombie Deadpool and how he came about
and all that kind of stuff well none of
that matters because he dies in the
first three pages of this story what is
up happening is it looks like it's dark
dark pool it looks like it's the dark
version of Deadpool that is basically
taking zombie head pool and putting his
head in a microwave now this entire con
this entire time we get some discussion
from zombie head pool he's talking about
how he's a comedic relief and someone is
so forth but the fact remains that at
the end of the days ah me head pools put
his head's put in a microwave and he's
blown up and so that's the end of him so
those of you guys who hated zombie
Deadpool this is your day you get to see
him go away now following this we
switched to Ryan Reynolds and Ryan
Reynolds is fighting a robot that is
basically terrorizing New York City now
the robot is given or I guess it's
design on behalf of a group called
ultimatum now ultimatum is a group we
haven't talked about yet but it's one of
the many terrorist groups like Hydra or
aim or something like that that looks to
basically overthrow governments of the
world and replace them with a kind of
totalitarian regime now ultimatum is
important
getting into the death of Deadpool
that's one of the big things going on
right now and so once we finish this
video we start to get into the death of
Deadpool when that time comes then we'll
get into a little more discussion about
ultimatum but for right now the only
thing we need to worry about is that
this robot is basically just tearing up
New York City especially just ripping
stuff up and so what happens is it
appears that while Ryan Reynolds is
fighting this ultimatum robot that the
Deadpool Corps arrived and the Deadpool
Corps arrived in their ship Bea Arthur
which of course looks like a giant
Deadpool and if they crash the ship into
the ultimatum robot and destroy it and
so Ryan Reynolds is actually shocked to
see the Deadpool cores here and so he
begins talking to them and what happens
is that lady Ryan Reynolds tells Ryan
Reynolds that that basically they're
being hunted down that they're being
tracked down that somebody and the in
the Marvel multiverse is killing off all
their multiversal counterparts and
they've established this kind of rebel
group this kind of a renegade group of
Deadpool's or I guess of Ryan Reynolds
that are going this is ridiculous
these renegade groups of Ryan Reynolds
that are trying to overthrow the evil
version of I guess overthrow dart pool
and so what happens here is as the group
is conversing and as you're talking
we're introduced to a couple new
versions of a variety of Reynolds that
is to say there's the Golden Age version
which really isn't significant here
because he actually dies really soon but
basically what happens is that while the
group is talking they're attacked by
what appears to be a version of dart
pool what appears to be dart pool
himself and so what happens is Golden
Age Ryan Reynolds is killed almost
immediately he simply just disintegrated
and so this evil version I guess his
dark pool begins to attack the rest of
the of the Deadpool Corps now from here
what happens is Ryan Reynolds the entire
time he's basically trying to figure
things out he's trying to understand
what in the world is going on here why
people are doing what they're doing why
it is or being attached so on and so
forth but at the same time he also wants
to take his own revenge against this
this version of dark pool for killing
off one of the members of the Deadpool
Corps and so what happens is he
basically uses the vocal patterns of
himself to body slide and what I mean by
that is for those of you guys who are
familiar with the relationship between
cable and Deadpool we knew that they had
been been friends for quite some time
but one of the pieces of technology that
Deadpool or I guess a cable how
as is the ability to body slide the
ability to use technology to a
physically teleport and he can teleport
by a factor of anything he can teleport
by a factor of 100 meaning he can body
slide himself alongside 99 other people
to any kind of location but most
commonly its body slide by one body
slide by two what Ryan Reynolds does is
he uses the vocal patterns of himself
and body slides half the body of this
dart pool away so that he's basically
torn in half and then he uses the ray
gun to disintegrate this this dark pool
body entirely and just kind of leave it
there and so what happens is the group
gathers and Bea Arthur and then they
immediately take off or what seems to be
the home base of the Deadpool core and
their base of operations with all these
other versions of Deadpool and so what
happens here as we see that our Ryan
Reynolds is speaking with everybody
trying to understand what's going on he
wants to know why it is they're being
hunted down why it is that they're being
killed off now of course he provides his
own manner of comedy and so on while I
was is happening but the fact remains
that the The Watcher I guess Avery a
watcher appears and basically tells Ryan
Reynolds he's going to be giving him the
rundown on why it is things are
happening but what's really cool about
this version of The Watcher is one it's
not who watching The Watcher and two he
loves the Deadpool Corps he's got all
this paraphernalia and all that kind of
cool stuff but it actually looks pretty
awesome but what we do before we
actually get into the watcher giving us
the rundown of what's happening with
everything I guess explaining all these
different things to Ryan Reynolds is we
switch to dark pool and so what we learn
here is that the Deadpool Corps when
they were being attacked by these evil
versions or these dark versions of dark
pool it wasn't actually dark pool proper
instead it was people fighting on his
behalf and so what happens here is it
seems as though he's basically a masked
and army dark pool has this army of all
these different versions of Deadpool we
of course see venom Deadpool we see bee
pool a version of Deadpool that has bees
around its mouth and what's really kind
of funny here is that evil Deadpool
which is a version of Deadpool this
piece together by all the different
versions of Deadpool himself use
basically uses his uses this gun to blow
off the head of people and the whole
reason is because he got tired of all
the buzzing coming from the mouths of
bees pool and that was it that was like
the only reason there was no other
reason besides that but what is up
happening is darn pool begins to speak
directly with
Deadpool and what he tells evil Deadpool
is one he's glad to have him back but
two they have a spy among the ranks of
the rebels and that they're basically
using information from the spy to
determine where it is the rebels are
hiding at and they're in turn going to
attack the group entirely and so what we
do is we pick up with the Watchers is
explaining everything to Ryan Reynolds
then what he says is that for the most
part somewhere well somewhere along the
line that evil I guess dark pool had
begun killing off all these different
versions of superheroes we of course
pretty much see The Watcher telling us
everything that had happened and
Deadpool killest rated Deadpool kills a
Marvel Universe and all the things
leading up to this point but the
difference here is that the watcher The
Watcher basically says that at some
point along the line dart pool came up
with the idea that the only way for him
to basically achieve his goal is to kill
off all the dead pools that exists in
the multiverse because they would be
able to stand in his way they would be
able to stop him so he can kill them all
off entirely or you can a suede them to
their cause which is why he has a huge
army of dead pools that are basically
fighting on his behalf and so as a
result what Lady Deadpool tells us so I
guess what lady Ryan Reynolds tells us
is that the I guess the dark version the
evil Deadpool core I guess the best way
to describe them that they've been using
a multitude of different ways to kill
off different different versions of
Deadpool because the question Deadpool
has or I guess where I'm Reynolds has is
if they have a healing factor how can
they die and what she says is that there
are weapons out there that can you
negate the healing factor of Deadpool or
various other versions of Deadpool there
are things out there that will just
consume their bodies entirely so there's
nothing to heal back from there's all
different manner of ways to kill off any
version of Deadpool and that's what dark
pool and his group have been using and
so what happens is the Deadpool Corps
lands on what appears to be their base
of operations which is like a giant
amusement park world now this is
probably the coolest thing ever like I
would love to live on a world where it's
just like amusement parks everywhere and
you just have like the most fun ever
like every day of your life like riding
rides and eating cotton candy and like
funnel cakes and all that kind of stuff
as long as it's not overpriced because
like amusement park stuff is overpriced
but nonetheless the fact remains that
what ends up happening here is once they
arrive at their base of operations they
realize that pretty much all the men
the Deadpool Corps who were there have
been destroyed they've been killed off
entirely
at the same time Ken Poole realizes that
it seems as though one of the members of
the Deadpool Corps is still alive and
when he goes to turn over the body he
discovers a booby trap and when is up
happening is there's this massive
explosion and Kidd pool is killed in the
process and so what happens is we see
that evil Deadpool arrives along with I
guess Wolverine pool and several other
people and the groups begin fighting one
another but in the midst of the conflict
we find that panda pool arrives and
panda pool is quite possibly the
greatest version of Deadpool to ever
exist in the history of all the dead
pools who have ever dead pooled like it
is he's so cool but he shows up and like
quite literally just starts like
destroying everybody I mean just like
swatting at people and scratching them
and like cut them in half ripping
people's heads off it's unbelievable I
guess it's one of the coolest things
ever and so as a result the forces of
evil Deadpool have kind of been
dwindling to a handful but what is up
happening is that while Ryan Reynolds is
fighting against evil Deadpool that The
Watcher begins to sort of narrate
everything that's going on he's
narrating the discussion saying
regardless of who wins and so on and
then evil Deadpool shouts out to the
watcher asking if he's going to help or
not and so this is when Ryan Reynolds
realizes that the spy that's been inside
the Deadpool Corps the entire time was
the watcher himself and so the question
of Ryan Reynolds asks is why would you
turn on the Deadpool Corps why would you
basically fight alongside this evil this
dark version of Deadpool and what uh
what The Watcher says is that he just
couldn't pick a side because all the
Deadpool's were awesome and so what
happens is that while the group is
carrying on while everybody is
continuing to fight again that galactus
full arrives and so what we're going to
do here is we're going to end this video
cliffhanger but we're going to go ahead
and leave this video to it and I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys
I'm hella fast Khitomer demands guys and
get so mascot place for then it's got
guns galore got a couple more see babes
and more with fair traps and hand
grenades pull the pistol like a maniac
right in your face pop it off sleep it
trailer trucks sitting on my chair
stretching my I can't I'm invincible but
if you like to drive